miguel monteiro que estágio fazer milhão
eu sei que eu tinha só vai de miguel
monteiro e elas vieram mall miguel quer
fazer legal rio perto da bandeirinha
favor da mudança já não esteja muito bem
vindo já o gol me irritar um jogador é
igual a uma dinâmica moderna chamada
usina melhor para que estas falhas foi
assessor foi desculpa ao senhor da
igreja pretende um bombom lindolfo
monteiro não passar seis meses porque
ele é de r 96 meses sem jogar o lixo nos
faz com que você esteja sempre ganhar
dinheiro pra pagar esta taxa subiu 7
milhão e basta irem buscar água enquanto
não chega o planejamento a fama recente
não conseguiu identificá-lo e meio eu
estou sempre fez muito calor junto meu o
meu deus é a melhor amiga custa muito
dinheiro também porque tinha a minha
culpa
essa cota não tem choro e miguel posso
abrir mão facilmente
hoje domingo eu fui a le morreu no hall
também na antártida é o dinheiro era do
chão porque tinha que ter ou não ter
ninguém mais pulsante porque o alarme a
funcionária no fim de fazer não
concessionais filho eu preciso ir união
não abandona os miguel miguel nada nem a
ninguém
é quem pode testar minha mãe tenho
miguel monteiro
eu sei que estarei miguel na comic con
feira a seis meses que não grava judô o
miguel monteiro pra completo nunca joga
em portugal
eu vou tomar miguel otero está tudo bem
legal eu posso que esteja perdendo ó
miguel deixa impune miguel olha que a
mesa se resolvem miguel ganso não parou
duas vezes e da cunha monteiro está o
carro não tem que andar com ele no
entanto a questão do miguel monteiro a
coisa mais preciosa dela e eu vou entrar
neste carro
eu adoro quando se olha o mesmo mas não
foi nada
o espanhol meu deus agora estamos sem
nada sentir isto para o carro sozinho
pergunta que não quer melhorar esta
pintura do carro novo não é por aí falei
olha só que bonito carro bonito né
agora está muito bonita festa gente
ok só acho que está bom
foto gero por dia entrando na oi oi e oi
assim assim miguel
eu sei que vai ficar com o carro é boba
encher muito mal como fim e não tem
estádio e divertir-se carlão é
carcereiro que ele escolheu
olha meu povo meu amigo elton e eu vou
deixar vou deixar a minha linha o que
aconteceu nada aqui não não chega nunca
meu amigo não tem censura que foi aquela
desculpa e flora que neste banco
o que você quiser e tomava cuidado com o
ambiente mudou a rota e nos quer que ele
não pode ganhar duas câmeras nem falou
que não vai junto comigo os meus fãs vão
te darei por 3 0 com golos de maltratos
miguel foto de morte foi a união não é
de estranhar muito estranha porque
querendo ou não o que sai de um percurso
no choro miguel com 514 33
não vale a pressionar se isso não for as
estrelas support centers milhão pois os
pais não era justo não é legal pois
expandir centro oeste e bob 18 horas o
homem formiga miguel mostrou o lado
família mostra madu formiga nesta tarde
com esse elenco foi melhor foram o
silêncio miguel foram chinês foi lá
outro dia tinha ganho o título lá foram
os chineses xu dos campeonatos ajudando
a china vai contra o que eles fizeram
assim você acaba no entanto não vai
saber que o filho é teu carro
o s boné união responde é meu que não
esquece porém foi muito caro falar nos
estados unidos a eles respondeu milhão
do cartaxo legal você não também da lei
está no chão e um cheiro a minha sorte
sempre estamos em crer que essa tinta
sai cubano foi então eu chegar aí dentro
olhas indochinesa setor cheiros o cheiro
é que você está em um lugar onde você
está em um lugar por falta um vidro
miguel falta-lhe um vidro de quais são
você tá ilegal você não pode acontecer
se eu acho simpático
vamos fazer agora dois jogos do meu
carro eu como o gás 9 miguel não queria
que a cheia de vida
ela caminhou nenhuma surpresa ela lembra
que a honda civic type r o que tinha e
que envolve estes lembra desse carro eu
comprei carro parati onde ela precisa é
a lei mas tem que limpar o carro mesmo
começar a montar esse é um pouco sujo eu
sou um pouquinho eo wando tatu tinham
chiquinho na escola e se exclui os
números chico destino à mão num bem
gostoso e maxixe nome dela eu não vou
lembrar porque eu vou fugir de casa
minha mãe não sabe brincar miguel votar
as pedras pedro miguel que não vai fazer
isso me angustia não levanta a mão aí
como eu cheguei a esse ponto eu vou te
matar não não há sim não e que nos
chegou a nota
disse que escolheu a feira muito mal num
não presta e foi difícil estava só a
brincar meio a um contexto china cara
com 13 gols e china cara legal
agora bola me só toque pessoal e vamos
colocar o nosso carro amarelo e tacacá
esquecer fácil eu sei que a chave o lyon
viu o carro concluiu rodrigo acaba meu
deus está no carro do be
eu ia para o carro lá vai meu eu ia pôr
o carro ela vai me ela é instrumento é
uma vergonha para o caso levaram miguel
já passou e ela só se tornarão o galo
não pensar muito que colocou uma colher
de hotel a fiel outra vez jogaram lá o
miguel mas ele é ou não mas olha pra
trás milhão de fazer com aluguel por
milhão
olha gente chega no cocó
sinto cheiro no local com miguel e
educadores lidam com cola branca esta
escola quando entra no cabelo não sai
muito perigosa mesmo tornou fácil de
casa
uma delas só está claro muito gol e
ganhou e isso já o meu boné amiga e
também está agitado ainda ontem mas eu
preciso conduzir o processo corre o
risco de só falarem cola branca é muito
agradável então nunca meu entender
melhor como é a cola miguel usa usa e
abusa e fui como irritar o jogador
no novo é nova